Dee aujourd'hui tu nous donnes
lesemp
deé éta aussi historien et archiviste
d'entreprise et j'ai une formation
historien archiviste et ça ça a été un
grand bonheur pour moi de réunir
différentes compétences acquises au
cours de ma
carrière les réunir au service de la
voix
voilà
Fabi après Denis
et sil peut y avoir une
caractéristique au cours de de toute ma
av c'est la notion de partage j'ai dit
oui à Pierre parce que d'abord le projet
de sur Vincent de Paul me plaisait
énormément je j'ai connu les Filles de
la Charité étant très jeune et elles
m'ont appris beaucoup de choses donc ça
m'a touché et puis d'abord j'aime
beaucoup la figure de Vincent de Paul et
puis pierre aussi c'est une figure c'est
quelqu'un à qui on peut faire confiance
voilà je l'ai vraiment profondément
ressenti ça au début à notre première
rencontre vous m'z invité à servir par
des œuvres de charité et bien celle-ci
m'occupera jusqu'à mon dernier
souffle un moment le spectacle est venu
au service de moi et là j'ai eu tout
j'étais pas
content du du filage et puis au bout
d'un moment ben c'était que j'étais pas
content de moi j'ai dit ouais tu
commences à avoir une pression et après
je suis dit cool mec euh tu es au
service et le spectacle il est pas au
service de toi et et donc il y a eu un
moment une friture qui est intervenue
comme ça et qui faisait que la
proposition était fausse CTA pe-être de
temps en temps un peu speed dans mes
manières de réagir donc je m'en excuse
on n'est pas là pour nous pour se mettre
en Scine pour se mettre Bou sur SC on
est là pour servir une proposition dont
on est convaincu qu'elle est belle
qu'elle est forte et qu'elle parle
aujourd'hui ça il dit vraiment moi je
suis le serviteur de Vincent vous êtes
l'incarnation de la Divine
Providence grâce à vous j'entrevois ce
qui viendra renouveler ce qui m'animait
lors que j'ai fondé les confreries des
dames de la
charité seul le dévouement des pauvres
peut apporter un secours sincère et
efficace au plus pauvres d'entre nous la
pauvreté ne leur fait pas peur elle est
leur lot quotidien
et ils ont plus à cœur d'en venir à vous
que ceux qui ne la connaîtront
jamais il y a parfois des cadeaux qui
pourraient ne pas paraître des cadeaux
mais j'ai eu un moment une belle
carrière et après j'ai eu la totale de
la descente aux enfers et le dénuement
la pouvreté matérielle aujourd'hui je
suis au rsa et euh et puis de la
alors ça ça c'est un beau cadeau qui m'a
été fait leè les ont abandonné et vous
aussi voudez les abandonner sachez le
vie
son moi je vous le dis notre seigneures
petits enfants pour les louanges qui
sortent de leur bouche monsieur V ne
Croz pasensible dé DEES enfants mais
regardez vos filles de charité sont
épuisé vivre dans la rue c'est mourir
faim ou être vendu et on n'est pas
sensible à toute la pression qui peut
renvoyer au pauvres une image
rabaissante et au contraire je je
m'active beaucoup pour dire attention
hein c'est notre joli champ ce n'est que
pour ton amour que les pauvres te
pardonnent le pain que tu leur donnes ce
n'est que ton amour que pre te
pardonne le temps que tu le
don je suis un petit peu dans un débat
entre demandez vous serez exaucé et
priez et dieu sait ce dont vous avez
besoin et ne demandez rien
alors il y a cette relation qui
s'établit dans la prière ce lien où on
est à disposition et
puis je prie beaucoup pour les
autres mais ça peut-être un anonyme
croisé dans la rue une détresse quelque
et voilà je prie pour toi la conclusion
c'est oser un autre regard sur l'autre
oser le regard du
cœur
y